m'aurait plu médecins en couverture mais
il me rappelle toi on s'était dit que
c'était trop proche de celle du mois
dernier ça avec le type qui avait
défenestré sa femme enceinte de six mois
tu sais un oui massif au boom alors que
les choses soient claires on a invité
ici pour que tu te reposes les meurtres
les psychopathes les bébés congelés là
toutes ces merdes qu'on trouve dans ton
torchon tu mets ça de côté
un seul mot d'ordre farniente
je suis vraiment désolé mais moi avec
une gueule comme ça je pardonne tout
votre soeur s'est pas fait gonfler les
lèvres
et vous vous êtes pas fait gonfler les
fesses doit homicide
je crois qu'il va falloir je reprenne
mon service mais quand je te disais que
c'était une vraie tahri ça va peut-être
comparaître action j'ai l'impression
qu'on me cache des choses un crime a été
commis et il s'agit de retrouver le
meurtrier
vous avez un peu trop vieux à scooby doo
vous savez dans scooby doo le grand chef
oui mais ça va je vous remercie je vois
très bien qu'ils aient scooby doo
je connais par coeur dans ta tête à
thème déjà le titre de ton article tu
veux quoi dégorger je veux pas vous
suivre comme ses délires il s'est
complètement à souder ses secrets pour
nous on appelle ça le calice service
votre céréales qu'il est en train de
prendre la fuite
ce que vous aurez du groupe r
faut pas croire ici on est à l'abri on
voit rien mais cette région c'est une
plaque tournante de la pègre ali mellah